in the crotch that's right they're
making these jokes sitting here about
Biden how about how [__] creepy he is
and this son of a [__] on the end is a
[__] sexual predator that's right and
they're all yucking it up Biden's a
creep because he's handing out candy to
kids on Halloween all the while the
[__] the the dick groper over here is
yucking it up too and they're all going
to go to the slap's house and get
grabbed by Matt schap I guess I guess
that's what they think Halloween's about
get the [__] out of here with this
[__] crazy [__] are you are you
[__] me this can't be real right
this has got to be AI it's got to be AI
with match slap sitting here as these
people are yucking it up about someone
being a sexual predator when they got a
[__] sexual predator sitting at the
goddamn table with them are you [__]
kidding me and then the one [__] says
that they're going to they're all going
to go to the slap's house where where I
guess you get that I mean that's normal
stuff where you get sexually molested on
Halloween I'm sure if the schlap sounds
get the [__] out of here this is the
[__] that these people are listening to
and you're wondering why why your farm
fresh fash Facebook Uncle Fred is
delusional [__] delusional and oh by
the way speaking of your your farm fresh
fash Facebook Uncle Fred it appears that
we're not going to have the government
open by
Thanksgiving I know I know I'm laughing
at it it's not really a laughable matter
but you know what it just shows how
inept they
are it just shows how inep they are I
mean here they are on Newsmax could
report on decent [__] [__] and here I
am having to goof on
them and show you this [__] that they're
watching this sludge that they're
pumping into these [__] people's puny
little manga brains where they ain't got
enough [__] brain cells to rub
together and that's why they're [__]
out [__]
turds Jesus
Christ I mean at least Newsmax could
have some goddamn
Integrity since they got the word news
in their name they're clearly not
[__] news
clearly but they got the [__] name or
the word in their name they could at
least
try to get some news out
that yeah the government's going to shut
down not only that it doesn't look like
the Republicans are going to pass
funding for Israel or Ukraine for that
matter not not going to do it doesn't
look like it to me I mean some people
are still staying optimistic around
Washington some commentators are
optimistic in Mike Johnson's ability
what
ability what a speak speaking of weirdos
and Matt schlap and people doing weird
things with
Children what about questioning why Mike
Johnson at the age of 25 as a single
man adopted a 14-year-old boy how about
that how about that you [__] weirdos
at Newsmax while you're sitting around
the table with a sexual predator casting
your projections onto Joe
Biden Jesus [__] Christ it never it's
just astounding to me and again this is
why I I almost doubt that this is even
real cuz this can't be real right this
can't
be but it is it is
real literally they biggest [__]
knock on Joe Biden now now I want to
tell you a little bit about this
week there's been a lot of stuff going
on this week but there is a there was a
huge Victory this week for the American
workers when Chevrolet finally announced
a ta a tentative agreement with the UAW
and I know that that feels like well
that ain't that big a bucket ain't
that's a big [__] deal that's a
really big [__]
deal that's a huge win in the Biden
column folks for what can be used in The
Narrative for the American working class
next year in the general election it's a
big [__] win and this CVS Walgreens
[__] if this gets worked out with a
strike the same thing because I almost
bet I almost bet that this President
United States who is the most pro-
American middle class president that I
have ever
seen probably since
FDR that this this pro-american middle
class working middle class president
will stand with those CVS and those in
those Walgreen workers and anyone else
who decides to strike to get their
[__] fair share of the GDP and the
profits that these companies use their
labor
for
he's going to stand with those American
workers and that's a huge win in the
column this week and you know what's
crazy is these [__] can't even
find a way to goof that think about that
for a second think about it for a second
they're sitting around a table with a
[__] accus sexual predator sitting at
the
end who is apparently a closeted gay man
who grabs dudes by the dick in a car and
sexually molest them okay that's what
he's [__] accused of don't come at me
that's what he's accused of they're
sitting around the table talking about
how Joe Biden's a sexual predator when
what they should be doing if they were a
good opposition if they were a good
opposition what they would be doing is
they would be trying to find a way to
spend a narrative that it's bad that the
unions are winning these fights which
that's the
point they can't find a way to spin a
narrative where it is good for the
American working class to not win these
labor Wars against these corporations
they can't do it they can't do it they
understand they understand that the
American people no matter who you are
whether you're for Biden or for Trump
whether you're for unions or against
unions it doesn't [__] matter when it
comes down to it when the question is
should workers get paid a decent [__]
w age especially when the corporation
they work for has mountains of
profit should they earn a decent [__]
wage they absolutely should earn a
decent [__]
wage and my guess is my guess is is that
no matter your ideology no matter where
you stand on a political Spectrum you
will agree with that statement that the
American working class deserves a decent
[__] wage and they deserve ve their
fair share of the profits of those
corporations that they work for and
that's why Newsmax is projecting as the
sexual molester sits at the end of the
table molesting
pumpkins oh wait I have a I have an
image of Matt SL schlap
here looks like he's trying to get his
hands on that
pumpkin weird stuff weird stuff in
American politics look at
that oh rat you're something else
everybody think think the labin you rat
bastard you rat bastard you really are
something you know
that he's good oh this guy this [__]
guy we're talking about match schlap
molesting it's Halloween the day after
Halloween and he produces this image how
does that make you feel about yourself
rant oh he's excited he's excited about
it well thank you R thanks for the
images today we'll keep going maybe
we'll find some more all right let's
keep going
um I don't know actually you know what
let's finish it up let's see if let's
see if match La says anything here at
the end I don't think he does but uh
let's see if he responds in any way to
her inviting herself to the molestation
party I mean the Halloween party with
kids he's going to be awkward he's going
to be coughing he's going to be
stumbling and fumbling over his words
maybe tripping on stairs all I know is
I'm going to the schaps house for
Halloween you guys out good candy bars
so you know forget the White
House oh they're gonna have good wine
did you hear that that's what he said at
the end listen listen to map if you hear
him you can hear him talk listen you
guys good candy bars so you know forget
the White House and we'll have good wine
a get you nice and drunk before I grab
you well you get you get you nice and
wasted give you that that good
candy that good candy and that good wine
all right before you get a good grabing
Jesus Christ are you [__] kidding me
snorton uh here uh you know this is our
Free Speech what is he gonna do send me
a cease and assist go ahead Ed snorton
send me a cease and assist that would be
F sneeze a sneeze and I don't know I
think I think I would get you know with
the pumpkin and the and the snorting I
think I would get probably a cease and
assist from match slap before that
here's one we had of him earlier match
laap likes to molest pumpkins here he
was yesterday on Halloween wow molesting
a
[Music]
pumpkin